dans le MIR biologiste et ces mystère au
changement climatique aux enjeux
nordiques du gouvernement du Québec vous
êtes dans l'équipe canadienne donc
québécoise dans ce cas-ci à la COP 15
bonsoir Monsieur le Maire
bonsoir Patrice bon
ça regarde pas très bien est-ce que
c'est moi qui comprend pas ça regarde
pas très bien
en fait si on s'était parlé hier je vous
dirais que ça s'est amélioré beaucoup
aujourd'hui je suis obligé de vous dire
que ça regarde pas très bien
effectivement ça varie beaucoup
je pense que nous sommes dans une
situation où vraiment je dirais que
l'avantage il va peut-être basculer j'ai
pas l'impression qu'on va sortir d'ici
avec avec une entente s'il y a pas un
fond
biodiversité qui est créé là bon il y a
des gens qui s'opposent à la beaucoup
s'opposent à la création de ce fond là
résultat ça peut être il faut envisager
l'échec de la conférence de Montréal
on n'est pas encore là parce qu'il reste
encore on a jusqu'à lundi peut-être même
mardi ce qui est intéressant c'est que
ce n'est pas juste le fond Patrice c'est
comment il sera qui va gérer ce fond là
l'annonce du Canada aujourd'hui pour le
fondant l'environnement mondial c'est
qu'on a déjà il existe déjà un mécanisme
mais bon les pays en développement
aimeraient avoir leur propre font
pourquoi parce qu'ils ne veulent pas
avoir du double comptage donc si vous
avez donné une subvention pour les
changements climatiques elle ne peut pas
compter à la fois pour la biodiversité
c'est ce qui va l'éviter beaucoup et on
voit beaucoup beaucoup de il y a pas
beaucoup d'ouverture du côté du Brésil
et des pays en développement donc ils
veulent vraiment leur fond un nouveau
fond et c'est ça qui est à chope en ce
moment donc pour résumer là parce que
Jean vous êtes là dedans vous dans tous
les détails prenons le code du Brésil le
Brésil dit à la planète vous voulez
qu'on protège l'Amazonie qu'on x
millions d'agrès c'est trop alors
parfait faites-nous des chèques
exactement et c'est intéressant parce
que vous avez vu
juste avant moi on a parlé de cette
coalition pour une autre ambition tous
ces pays qui sont pour le 30%. le Brésil
n'est pas dans le 30% pourquoi pourtant
ils sont très très près là il manque
quelques points de pourcentage ils
peuvent y arriver facilement mais c'est
une technique de négociation qui est
souvent employée alors si vous nous
faites un gros chèque je vais vous dire
oui de l'autre côté donc on est vraiment
dans les jeux de corridor là et c'est
intéressant pour je dirais pour les
diplomates qui sont ici évidemment pour
le public ça devient extrêmement
difficile à suivre tout ça mais disons
que c'est une question d'argent Patrice
au final c'est vraiment ça qui va
déterminer si on a un cadre mondial
ambitieux je vous dirais mardi prochain
mais ça peut ça peut jouer encore
et qui déterminera si elle est chèque
sont envoyés ou pas est-ce que c'est
l'Europe et les États-Unis
en fait je vous dirais normalement la
présidence chinoise c'est là qu'elle
vient jouer un rôle très très important
je vais pas faire de d'impair
diplomatique mais disons que le rôle du
Canada en ce moment est très précieux
parce que quand il a un certain silence
au niveau de la présidence mais c'est le
pays haute qui prend la relève et je
dois avouer que le Canada en ce sens
fait beaucoup beaucoup d'efforts pour
rallier justement les pays qui auront
les moyens de faire ces fameux chèques
donc chapeau là-dessus au Canada devant
un certain silence de la présidence en
ce moment ok mais pour que je comprenne
vous dites
non seulement les Chinois veulent pas
signer le chèque mais ils sont
silencieux un deux les Américains les
Européens se font tirer l'oreille et les
Américains sont pas claires
en fait on s'entend ça va prendre plus
de flexibilité du côté de l'Union
européenne par exemple ce qu'on voit
nous dans les négo et donc il va falloir
que les partenaires qui sont normalement
tous les alliés du Canada travaillent
ensemble pour essayer de dénouer cette
question de fond évidemment qui est
vraiment au coeur Patrice du succès de
cette commande alors je vais relier
cette question du fond aux questions
dont les gens entendent parler depuis le
début ça faisait la protection de 30%
d'espace sur la planète
si on arrive pas à s'entendre sur ce
fond là le sud dit au nord vaut 30%,
allez voir passerez nous on continue on
développe puis on a besoin de développer
parce qu'on a un retard c'est un peu
seul c'est ça la grande négociation qui
a lieu
en fait ce que les pays en développement
dit c'est vous nous demandez de
participer à une très grande ambition
qui est justifiée évidemment par l'État
je dirais de la nature c'est ce que les
scientifiques disent donc si vous voulez
qu'on ait de l'ambition et qu'on aille
vers le 30 %, mais donnez-nous les
moyens pour y arriver donc en gros on
comprend très bien cette logique là
c'est simplement Patrice que quand on
regarde ce qui se passe en climat par
exemple bah il y a un fond de 100
millions en climat il y aura un nouveau
fond pour perte et préjudice qui a été
décidé et là un fond en biodiversité
donc je comprends aussi le point de vue
de l'autre côté avec les pays riches qui
disent ben ça fait beaucoup beaucoup de
fonds à gérer et beaucoup d'argent donc
on est vraiment là-dedans si on veut de
l'ambition comme si on veut créer ce
fameux moment Montréal ça va prendre des
sous et s'il n'y a pas de moments
Montréal si on s'entend pas puis là bon
elle est chacun vous allez dire on a
fait quand même des progrès si on
s'entend pas il arrive on se revoit
quand exactement
c'est une bonne question les les
scénarios pour un échec ne sont pas non
pas été
mis de l'avant là vraiment pas on sait
par contre on l'a vu ce matin il y a 116
pays que ce sont engagés pour le 30%, ça
se bloque là ne bougera pas est-ce que
il pourrait y avoir une division puis
dire bon ben nous on continue sur le 30%
mais je pense qu'il reste encore
beaucoup d'espoir
exactement on est comme on rentre dans
les séries là et donc là c'est ce qui
compte c'est d'envoyer notre meilleur
trio sur la glace très bien Jean Lemire
on va suivre ça en fin de semaine les
gens vont suivre dans les bulletins
nouvelles un peu partout dans les
journaux et ça se termine en principe
lundi je le rappelle mais peut-être
lundi très tard peut-être mardi matin on
verra qui c'est Jean-Louis on se
reparlera merci beaucoup
merci Patrice au revoir